[YELLING]
>> YOU COULD HAVE MADE A
DIFFERENCE!
>> Harris: PROTESTS ERUPTING
ACROSS THE NATION, THIS YEAR AS
PARENTS LOOK TO RECLAIM THEIR
RIGHTS OVER THEIR CHILDREN'S
EDUCATION.
IT'S WHO YOU REMEMBER HOW THAT
WAS.
AND IT HAS LAUNCHED THE ISSUE OF
THE FOREFRONT OF THE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS.
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS SET TO
ADDRESS THE NATIONAL EDUCATION
ASSOCIATION THIS AFTERNOON.
THE NEA IS ONE OF THE NATION'S
LARGEST TEACHERS UNIONS.
THE PRESIDENT'S SPEECH COMES AS
REPUBLICAN LAWMAKERS IN PRODUCE
LEGISLATION TO END THE CHARTER
FOR PUSHING WOKE IDEOLOGY.
THE VICE PRESIDENT PRAISING THE
GROUP THAT ACTUALLY DUG UP DIRT
ON PARENTS WHO QUESTIONED THEIR
AGENDA FOR OUR CHILDREN.
>> AND WE STILL HAVE MORE TO DO.
AND WE HAVE SO MUCH TO DO
TOGETHER.
NEA, YOU ARE AN EXTRAORDINARILY
EFFECTIVE AS A GROUP ADVOCATE
FOR CHANGE, WHICH IS WHY WE KNOW
THAT YOU HAVE BEEN ABLE TO SEE
THE SUCCESS YOU HAVE ACHIEVED.
AND IT IS NO SURPRISE WHY,
BECAUSE WE KNOW UNIONS KNOW HOW
TO ORGANIZE.
>> Harris: LIKE THAT IS
SUPPOSED TO MEAN SOMETHING.
TAMMY BRUCE, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR AND HOST OF "GET
TAMMY BRUCE ON FOX NATION."
TAMMY, WHY COULDN'T THEY
ORGANIZE SOMETHING OVER THE
SUMMER SO THAT OUR KIDS COULD
CATCH UP?
WHY COULDN'T THEY ORGANIZE WITH
THOSE UNIONS TO SPEND SOME OF
THAT COVID RELIEF MONEY AND NOW
THE PRESIDENT SAYS?
>> BECAUSE LIKE WITH UNIONS,
PEOPLE AT THE TOP GET VERY RICH.
AND STOPPED TEACHERS LONG AGO,
WHEN THE VICE PRESIDENT SAID A
WORD THAT STARTED WITH CH, I
THOUGHT SHE WAS GOING TO STAY
CHILDREN, BUT SHE DIDN'T, SHE
SAID CHANGE, BECAUSE IT IS GREAT
FOR -- I THOUGHT CHILDREN, BUT
OF COURSE THEY DON'T, OF COURSE
HE WOULD NOT SAY THAT.
UNIONS NOW ARE FRONTS FOR LEFT
ORGANIZERS.
AND EVERYONE ATTACHED TO IT BY
PROXY, CHILDREN OR TEACHERS OR
WORKERS ARE EXPENDABLE.
THEY ARE LIKE AN EXCUSE, THEY
ARE A SHADOW IN THE MIDST OF
WHAT THE LEFT IS DOING.
THAT'S WHY EVERYTHING IS
COLLAPSING.
NO ONE HAS MADE A COMMITMENT AND
CERTAINLY THEY PRETEND TO CARE
ABOUT WHO THEY ARE IN CHARGE OF,
BUT THIS IS PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT AND WE MUST REMOVE
GOVERNMENT FROM ANY KIND OF
LEGITIMACY FROM THE NEA, BECAUSE
WE HAVE KIDS NOW WE KNOW ARE
BEHIND TWO AND THREE YEARS
BECAUSE OF MISSING ONE YEAR, AND
NOBODY IS THINKING ABOUT HOW DO
WE CATCH THESE KIDS UP, THAT IS
WHO THINKS ABOUT THAT.
AND THAT'S WHY PARENTS NEED TO
HAVE POWER BACK AND RECOGNIZING
THAT THEY SHOULD BE IN CHARGE OF
THIS MONEY SO THAT THEIR
CHILDREN GET WHAT THEY NEED.
>> Harris: NOT JUST MISSING
THE YEAR, BUT WHEN THEY DID TRY
TO LEARN ON THOSE DEVICES, MANY
OF THEM COULD NOT DO THAT.
IT TAKES A CERTAIN TYPE OF
ATTENTION SPAN TO DO THAT.
MY KIDS WERE GETTING HEADACHES.
I MEAN, SERIOUSLY.
THEY HAVE COVID MONEY THAT THE
PRESIDENT SAYS THAT A PANDEMIC
IS OVER, LET'S SPEND THAT ON
GETTING OUR KIDS TO SHORTEN THAT
GAP AND HAVE THESE UNIONS PUT
THEIR TEACHERS TO WORK DURING
THE SUMMER.
ANYWAY.
"WALL STREET JOURNAL" OP-ED,
HERE'S A QUOTE, A VERY
INTERESTING OP-ED IN
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" TODAY.
IF YOU ARE A TOMBOY OR A
FEMININE BOY, IF YOU HAVE AN
EXPRESSION OR BEHAVIOR THAT IS
DIFFERENT FROM WHAT IS TYPICALLY
ASSOCIATED WITH YOUR-BASED ON
TRADITIONAL EXPECTATIONS, YOU
ARE TRANSGENDER.
NO WONDER SO MANY YOUNG PEOPLE
THINK THEY NEED MEDICAL HELP TO
CORRECT THEIR SEX.
>> YOU HAVE CHILDREN THAT DON'T
FIT IN, SO YOU JAM THEM INTO A
FREAKING BOX AND MAKE THEM BE
WHAT YOU THINK IT SHOULD BE,
CHILDREN GROWING UP BEHAVE AND A
LOT OF DIFFERENT WAYS, YOU CAN
BE A TOMBOY, YOU CAN BE OF
PERFECTLY HAPPY HETEROSEXUAL
WOMAN.
YOU CAN GROW UP AND BE PERFECTLY
HAPPY GAY WOMAN.
BUT YOU HAVE ADULTS DECIDING
WHAT THAT MEANS AND WHERE YOU
BELONG, AND THAT'S FROM THE LEFT
THAT SAYS WE ARE ALL FOR PEOPLE
BEING WHOEVER IT IS THEY
IMAGINE, BUT NOT WHEN YOU START
WITH CHILDREN.
THAT'S WHERE ADULTS START TO
IMPRESS THEIR ISSUES ONTO
CHILDREN AND THAT IS THE BIGGEST
ABANDONMENT OF CHILDREN WE HAVE
SEEN IN THIS COUNTRY IF NOT IN
HUMAN HISTORY AT THIS POINT.
>> Harris: REALLY QUICKLY WHAT
YOU ARE BASING SOME OF THIS ON,
NOT YOU, BUT THE PEOPLE WHO SAY
IF YOU ARE A TOMBOY, YOU ARE
THIS AND THAT, BUT THERE ARE A
LOT OF US WHO JUST DRESSED
CERTAIN WAYS WHENEVER WE WANT TO
ADDRESS CERTAIN WAYS.
AND THAT DOESN'T HAVE ANYTHING
TO DO WITH ANYTHING.
WHAT BOX DO YOU PUT PEOPLE AND
WHEN THEY JUST ARE BEING
THEMSELVES?
>> THERE IS STYLE.
WHEN I WAS A LITTLE KID I JUST
SIMPLY WANTED TO DO ALL THE
THINGS THAT THE BOYS WERE
ALLOWED TO DO BECAUSE AT THAT
POINT --
>> Harris: LOOK AT MY FIRST
NAME!
>> SPIRITUALLY YOU HAVE
ATTITUDES THAT EMERGE, AND HOW
DARE THESE ADULTS WHO ARE REALLY
PROJECTING IN THEIR ISSUES AS
ADULTS ONTO CHILDREN WHEN A
CHILD'S LIFE IS VARIED IT'S
WHERE YOU WOULD NOTICE WHAT YOU
LIKE AND WHAT YOU DON'T, AND
IT'S YOUR CHOICE.
AS A FEMINIST, ALSO AS A GAY
WOMAN AND IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
CHILDREN AND ADULTS CONTINUE TO
REALIZE THEY ARE IN CHARGE.
WHO WE BECOME IS US AS
INDIVIDUALS.
AND TO NOT HAVE PEOPLE FORCE US
OR MOVE US INTO A DIRECTION.
EVERY CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT WAS
ABOUT STOPPING NETS.
ENDING THE JUDGMENT OF OTHERS,
BECAUSE WE WERE DIFFERENT, NO
MATTER WHO WE ARE, AND HOW THEY
ARE GOING BACK TO IT.
>> Harris: WOULD LOVE TO TAKE
THE PLACE OF THE OTHER
FOUNDATION THAT HELPS DECIDE OUR
INDIVIDUALITY.
>> THAT IS GOD ITSELF.
>> Harris: DEMOCRATS PUSH TO
MAKE ABORTION A MAJOR MIDTERM
ELECTION ISSUE, GEORGIA
GUBERNATORIAL CANDIDATES FOR
GOVERNOR STACEY ABRAMS IS STILL
GETTING ROASTED FOR A COMMENT
SHE MADE WERE LOADS OF PEOPLE
ARE CALLING STRAIGHT UP AND
SAYING WHAT SHE SAID.
HERE IT IS.
>> THERE IS NO SUCH THING AS A
HEARTBEAT AT SIX WEEKS.
IT IS A MANUFACTURED SCAM
DESIGNED TO AND CONVINCE PEOPLE
THAT MEN HAVE THE RIGHT TO TAKE
CONTROL OF A WOMAN'S BODY.
>> Harris: PLANNED PARENTHOOD
MADE A STUNNING MOVE TO BACK HER
UP ON THAT.
THE ABORTION PROVIDER ALTERED
ITS WEBSITE TO CHANGE WORDING
THAT A FETUS HAS A VERY BASIC
BEATING HEART AT SIX WEEKS, THE
NEW WORDING IS THIS, IT SOUNDS
LIKE A HEARTBEAT ON AN
ULTRASOUND, BUT IS NOT A FULLY
FORMED HEART.
DR. SIEGEL SAID EARLIER THAT
THAT IS WHERE THE HEART BEGINS
ITS FORMATION, AND YOU CAN TALK
ALL DAY LONG ABOUT WHETHER OR
NOT ONE PERSON HEARING A
HEARTBEAT, BUT ANOTHER ONE NOT
QUITE YET TO DEFINES ANYTHING.
HE SAYS THAT ALSO IS INDIVIDUAL
JOURNEY.
>> OBVIOUSLY WHEN YOU ARE
LOOKING AT THE BEGINNING OF THE
FORMATION OF THE HEARTS, THERE
IS ACTION, THERE IS ELECTRICAL
IMPULSES, AND AT THE ELECTRICAL
IMPULSES WHICH IS WHAT THE HEART
OPERATES ON FOR ALL OF US AT
THIS VERY MOMENT IS MOVING THAT
MUSCLE AND THAT HAS BEGUN
DEVELOPMENT.
NOW WHAT THEY WANT, AND THIS
TELLS YOU SOMETHING.
IN A NO AND RECOGNIZING A
HEARTBEAT, THE ACTION OF THAT
BODY, THE MOVEMENT, THE LIFE
EMERGING INTO IT IS A PROBLEM
FOR THEM, SO THEY WANT TO
DISMISS IT.
THEY WANT TO DEHUMANIZE THAT
FETUS AS A BABY, AND THAT IS,
WHAT DOES IT TELL YOU ABOUT THE
LEFT?
THEY WANT TO DEHUMANIZE THINGS.
THE RIGHT IS TRYING, AT LEAST
CONSERVATIVES TO RECOGNIZE THE
LIFE THAT WE ALL LIVE AND
EXPERIENCE.
IT IS HORRIBLE, IT WAS GHOULISH,
AND THIS IS WHAT THE DEMOCRATS
DO.
IT IS UNACCEPTABLE TO LIBERALS
AND CONSERVATIVES ALIKE.
>> Harris: WHAT IT TELLS ME
WHEN WE WATCH THE POLLING, THE
AGGREGATE POLLING, NOT JUST ONE,
CLEAR POLITICS A TON OF THEM
THAT THIS ISSUE OF ABORTION FOR
DEMOCRATS MAY NOT BE TAKING AS
HOT AS THEY THOUGHT IT WOULD UP
AGAINST INFLATION AND OTHER
THINGS.
THAT'S WHAT IT TELLS ME.
>> IN OUR GENERATION AND THE
21ST CENTURY, WE KNOW TOO MUCH
AB